hey guys today it is the 30th of May my
name is Jessa and you're tuned into
games what news lionhead studios and
fable legends may have fallen under the
axe but a new fable game is on its way
to Kickstarter next week a group of X my
head developers have formed a new studio
called flaming pearl studios who intend
to finish the creation of fable watching
a digital card game based on the fable
RPG series Microsoft has agreed to let
the fable license be used by the new
studio whose members begin development
on fable fortune back in 2014 originally
pitched for fable two the game is
described as similar to half stone with
the addition of a cooperative mode and a
leveling system for cards the game also
features mid-game quests where players
can make a choice between good and evil
that will impact their cards and chosen
hero character the Kickstarter campaign
will open tomorrow and hopes to raise
250,000 pounds able fortune will have
both a closed and open beta after the
fundraising campaign finishes and will
release in late 2017 Sega recently sent
a survey out to fans which may reveal
some of the publishers intentions for
everybody's favorite new pet hug the
survey included questions like words one
would associate with Sonic what sports
match sonic the best and how interested
you'd be in crossovers the survey asked
about interesting game starring Sonic as
well as characters from other Sega and
non Sega games it then goes on to ask if
you'd want to see a Sonic game that
featured characters from Nintendo disney
dragon ball z Capcom my little pony and
adventure time elsewhere in the survey
you can also elect whether you think
sonic game should be exclusively action
game
digital foundry have posted a technical
analysis of the somewhat shaky for
harbor DLC for fallout 4 the report
states that after the 1.6 patch the
game's new area runs at 20 frames per
second although it can dip to 15 on ps4
digital foundry added as things dance PS
fours current performance profile sees
the father of a region present one of
the most sluggish regions in the game
while xbox one consistently runs at a
higher refresh culprit appears to be far
harbors new fog effects which are
causing the consoles to struggle that
des des has said we are actively working
on more improvements let me know down in
that comment section if you've been
struggling with far harbour and be sure
to head to gamespot we've got stories on
kd3 and the widget next big update that
is everything I got you today as always
thanks for sticking around and I will
see you again tomorrow